[Music]
very last summer on the show we had this
very kind of fun conversation where you
were and you admitted to not being very
athletic growing up yeah I tried
swimming but it was exhausting yeah
who's who starts swimming and thinks
it's not gonna be exhausted it's the
most exhausting thing you can do but you
think it wouldn't be but it's it's
pretty tiring yeah yeah no you think it
Michael Phelps works at it yeah that's
your excuse well anyway sue thought we
had that conversation you were invited
to throw out the first pitch yeah that
Dodgers game and yeah so how do you
before we show any tape how do you feel
it went well I actually wasn't I
surprisingly I wasn't that nervous about
it because since I wasn't that much into
sports i I just wasn't nervous but I
should have been cuz my pitch was awful
your pitch wasn't great well here's the
particle that I didn't that I didn't
appreciate on your behalf
okay which is during the game I know if
you saw this but you're sitting in the
stands and the commentators yeah they
cut to you and start talking about your
pitch it was before the game which I
didn't think was Burnett let's take a
look at that clip right now Tony Hale
threw out the first pitch before the
ballgame I talked to him a little bit he
was frankly a nervous wreck and I said
you're gonna be fine don't worry about
it but then when I saw him throw the
pitch I understood why he was so
terrified because frankly it was a
disaster yeah justifiably nervous that
was a horrible first pitch I mean if you
watch beep imagine how his character
Gary would throw out the pitch he'd be
scared to death just like he is on the
show all the time and Tony
I think I think the fact that you you
got it Thank You catcher
thank you you know that's that's a long
story I like to call that bullying yeah
screw those guys yeah yeah yeah
squirrel Maul I say but it was very fun
it was very very fun was that now that
was you sitting with your family that
was my wife and my 10 year old daughter
who is fan of ice cream
[Laughter]
you